[Music]
How do I help Héctor Mejía with his
brief information? Today is Wednesday,
September 15. All workers in the
state with close contact with
vulnerable people must now be vaccinated
against the coronavirus. Governor
Styps affirmed this new
emergency rule on Tuesday after.  of a vote of
4 to 0 by
the state health board, employees will be asked for proof by
the first of November
for more details visit our note in
teach dotcom the section in Spain'
and if you have not yet been vaccinated and want to
do so  we tell you that there will be some
ulna vaccination clinics
this week one will happen tonight
at duty and parc again las vegas this
park is about biggest come back
and select the clinic it will be from 5 to 8
at night another one will happen on friday in
mérida that will be closer to plan your
money is from 4 to 7 at night for a
complete list you can visit our
social networks page
est  a night if it's at school it
will only deny celebrates hispanic heritage month
this event is suitable for the
public and completely free it will be from
5 to 7 p.m. within three rounds
and sons is turin and union in the
establishment of new  rafters there will be
tacos giveaways and live entertainment
including a performance by the mariachi
plata the mariachi is nationally recognized
and now a look at the
weather forecast we will have a sunny day for today
wednesday hot reaching 102
degrees however we will see a drop
in temperatures already  We'll be in
the nineties for the rest of the week.
Have a nice day. I'm Héctor Mejía
and this was your brief information on
Kirchner in Spanish.
[Music]